citation needed join me today who reads
books you know it's Chris Joel hello
everybody's favorite Gary Brannen Gary
Brannen I'm cock-a-hoop and the Banshees
man on the Internet great
this is a public service announcement
these public services are closed please
use the nearest toilets on the other
side of the concourse in front from
Wikipedia and these folks can't see it
every fact with it right is a point and
a ding and the special prize for
particular dancers which is and today we
are talking about the Battle of fish
guard
there's a fish guard a shield yes they
hold it in their little battle is why
they called Boreas let's call them
warriors will they worry is holding up
fish's shield well I just like a
flatfish and a swordfish in the other
hand no I'm gonna say whales yes and
have a point it's a place yes yeah I
learnt it in a be no annual I learned it
from the shipping forecast well there we
go we all have different routes to
education fish card is applies in whales
and this is where the battle took place
no really
they named the battle after where it
happened unlike all the other battle
naming conventions before a good 50
miles away just to confuse the future
tourists
yeah so saying World War 2 we switch the
road signs around this affair point
battle and about actual stay at the
Battle of Hastings is debatable for
instance so yeah it has been done but
not of Waterloo you could see the
remains in Waterloo station to this day
that's true you wouldn't have thought
that having so close to London with you
that's just a Friday night before
Christmas omens from Napa fell out
when you turn it suppor our deeds um
this was a battle in Fishguard who might
have been attacking and when fishermen
actually I was gonna go for troll
ammonia oh no no it's a little early for
trawlers see it wasn't an uprising Oh
was it Vikings it's a little late for
Vikings so it's somewhere between
Vikings and the advent of modern fishing
where we sit the best well using my
extensive historical knowledge bracing
myself carry on it's not Victorian what
that was the only other time period I
know I'm gonna go 13th century no it's
much later this was during the War of
the first coalition well is that
political joke incoming is that
somewhere around about 2010 this was
1792 to 1795 been battling them
virtually everybody Tom does the wheel
spin and land as it does 50 percent of
the time on France this was an attempt
to land a force of French troops in
Britain to support another invasion
so they went via Wales yes soft
underbelly of England so where might
have been the primary attack force
headed Island yes oh hang on cuz there's
whales boat wise is on the way to
Ireland isn't it boating from the France
pit you get to the whales pit before you
get to the island bit die if you're
going from the right top right bit of
France yes he's not the depends on which
direction you're heading so what was
this invasion force intended to do
invade that is technically a correct
answer
this is a third attempt invasion why did
some of the earlier ones fail far too
windy yeah having beans on the journey
Lou indie-pop round so the whales bound
invasion force 1,400 troops from the
Black Legion Legion wah under the
command of an Irish American Colonel
William Tate within the Black Legion
from our side
no this is look well I'm translating the
leash on tight rings about those
actually did they did they invade with
art Tate no it actually wasn't recently
enough for modern art oh thank you so
each person takes a single clappity joke
and on average one clap a greater degree
of shade over 1400 troops
invading Wales essentially did anyone
ask the well sure they all right with
this sounds dreadfully rude well you say
that there was a bit of a response when
when 1400 troops arrived what were these
troops made up of horses cavalry no
influences riding men was a real diverse
600 were regular soldiers that Napoleon
had not required to conquer Italy so the
bTW yes 800 were irregular x' now what
does that mean slight factory seconds
maybe some chips in the glaze but still
useful irregular czar paid mercenaries
aren't they um not quite conscript again
not not quite it's more general so
they're a special force but not in an
SAS kind of way yeah Justin there's
something different about their special
they're specializing you wouldn't trust
him with anything important yes right
sorry House is good we have team and we
have the irregular 's and actually I am
gonna give you a point because it
includes Republicans deserters con
Victor's and royalist prisoners night
now
at least that last category is probably
not going to be that up for this what I
imagine they're gonna choose this as a
running away opportunity um yeah you
know what
discipline broke down amongst the
regulars on library delightful euphemism
discipline broke down amongst these
prisoners that we try to order into
doing something nice you running away
while you're at it I want you all here
my tea time you understand your honor
and yes they did indeed desert where and
why might they have deserted because
they're being forced to do things
against their will in a foreign nation
oh but very specifically they went to
try and do something cocktail bars they
just want some fish and chips and
they've found a place on the map called
fish place or every was called I mean it
wasn't so much they were paying for the
fish and chips did they steal fish and
chips
they just got wet looting that is
exactly the right word yes robbers booty
yes
you mean these people who we've arrested
for stealing we've let them go of their
own free will of stealing again let's
not forget we've given them rifles the
set up for the battle if you like I
don't there's probably a formal term for
the armies are massing themselves and
getting ready to fight it is it's the
armies are massing themselves and
getting a Marella ready to fight the
army to mask themselves and got ready to
fight but that took a little while so on
the French side they're sort of taken
over a few farmhouses what's happening
in the British command T a social event
is happening a messenger on horseback
arrives to instruct the commanding
officer and the commanding officer was
William Knox um what was his immediate
reaction lunchtime the thing is you're
about right Wednesday the crime
now you may speak the infant not about
that the import of this news was slow to
dawn on Knox
[Applause]
really the nice title here is battle
averted ah so what happened pint of rum
for anybody who switches sides oh you
know what two pints if room for anybody
Sarge
mercy for anybody something for
switching sides will same tape all day
it's not quite switching sizes what a
discipline among the recruits had
collapsed once they discovered the local
supply of wine today themselves were
drunk why might there have been wine in
whale stolen medicinal stolen is clothes
stolen the bread Ethan this wine is
German Christmas it's actually
Portuguese wine washed up yes Oh
Portuguese ship them and read some wine
because they're on the left a bit so
Portuguese version of maddewar probably
sank and some that were full of probably
port well let's go really isn't it I
only wish I got it through better means
while the British are marching in what's
happening with the locals are they
rapidly sobering the friendship to get
them to actually have this fight they
fancied chasing them out in with like
comedy implements like people chasing
might we roll in pins and you know what
the French are approaching the British
under the command of Lord Corridor whose
HQ is where Mordor I mean no the local
pub the Royal Oak really he set up in
the pub that was his HQ so he's taking
his men it's a very drunken invasion on
both sides this pubs could be used for
official uses because they were like a
community often you often had in quests
and things that took place in the local
pub or not on the top of the bar that'll
be rude but in an upstairs room so
suddenly someone kicking a door and
going mine now was probably quite you
they were probably quite used to it
could use his court rooms and things as
well you just go over to the winter
storm wait for all to blow over
pretty much the French realize that the
British had more people than that so as
the light fails they are back to their
camps for the night the next morning
what happens at the pub well the British
get up and realise that there's nothing
left in the pub and therefore after seek
out things like bacon sandwiches
possibly a McDonald's something I just
to get him over the night before who
comes along to the bottle the French
come along to the pub yes two French
officers turned up why would they do
that they too were in search of bacon
sandwiches why'd you send only two
officers to the opponent's HQ because
one of them's a horse hasn't been riding
on the back of the man knocks on the
door with it whose specific word here oh
my god we started negotiating the terms
of surrender surrender absolutely right
yeah they wish negotiate a conditional
surrender and Lord corredor said now yes
yes you're right that's what I said why
did he say that because he hadn't had a
fight yes and he come all this way and
brought all those things and he was hung
over and god damn it somebody was going
to suffer and he's being too early in
the morning by these bloody French oh
well after 1:00 he hasn't got the papers
with him or anything
does he not have the authority to accept
it no he absolutely has the authority to
accept it didn't want to yes why might
he have done that
why might've turned turned away a
conditional surrender and insisted and
that no it's got to be unconditioned so
an easy career promotion with a crushing
victory Oh crushing victories
interesting crushing loss a slight
glance an impropriety a society party no
he was saying we can get a crushing
victory essentially to them was he
getting a bonus if he won no he was
bluffing he was flat-out bluffing that
he had more people and more on the way
and if you don't surrender you will all
die there are no conditions on this you
can't come into the pub because it's
full of men full of them you need all of
them well no you Carla you simply can't
come through the door I can't I set your
surrender there's far too many of us by
well that's and so there is some
speculation here that he got a little
bit of help from some people looking on
from the cliffs so what did the French
see on the cliffs people to turn of the
18th century does anyone know what a
traditional Welsh costume looks like for
women yes the pointy hat and the little
a printed the title and the figure that
yeah yeah like that you look like a
little Welsh woman and all that spoons
at this out at the seaside resorts they
sell spoons all right they have low
flavors on them I'll give you the point
it's a top hat on a red dress yeah now
if you're looking at someone far away on
the top of a Polish you didn't think
you'd seen more soldiers today yes
as they had a shock oh and a red and the
Redcoats so he's confused a bunch of
watching Welsh women for it for a force
of infantry is what I say is the
speculation that he looked up at the top
of the cliffs and thought it's a lot of
people out there they look like soldiers
would invent glasses too whatever
happens in your life whatever it is
you're never gonna be the man who
confuse a load of Welsh women in
traditional dress for backup
so what are the French do runaway
unconditional surrender yes I'll give
you the point the French surrender the
British accept it
Tate is imprisoned briefly and then
returns to France along with most of the
force there is something about this
invasion though there is something 1797
this was and has something special about
it some that is marked out every time on
every little map every little memorial
plaque about this there was something
about the invasion of mainland Britain
in 1797 that will be the last invasion
of mainland Britain going back to the
start of this so it's not thrown
together 1066 which what everyone else
thinks it is yes you're absolutely right
the Battle of Fishguard was the most
recent landing on mainland written by a
hostile foreign force as we record this
congratulations Gary you in this show
you have won a device to help call the
lower jaws of South American rodents
it's a chinchilla chinchilla running
tonight gray I'm stopping we'll see you
next time
[Laughter]
you